let's bring in our guest co-host wwe
super couple
mike and maurice is it mike or is it ms
well it depends if you want me to be a
bad guy or a good guy
miz is the bad guy mike is the good guy
we want the good guy here today all
right quick pop quiz for both of you
what's your favorite britney spears song
oh that's easy oops i did it again oh
well it could be a long time before we
see britney perform any song live again
because she just suffered a big loss
in her conservatorship case brittany is
quote
afraid of her father she's had dark days
because of him and will not perform
again
if her father is in charge of her career
those were just some of the arguments
brits attorneys made
for removing jamie spears as her
conservator other factors
britney's mom lynn also wants her
ex-husband out
court papers also claim jamie cost the
singer nearly 309
000 in bad business dealings jamie's
attorney fired back
pointing out that the 68 year old has
helped britney go from
in debt to worth well over 60 million
dollars
jamie said he wants to hear from
brittany directly and not through her
attorney
the reason why britney's father may want
to insist that britney
is present in court is there's always a
concern
that people are talking for brittany and
taking advantage of her
i just want to let you guys know that i
am fine i'm the happiest i've ever been
in my life
one of the risks of having britney speak
directly to the court
is that oftentimes and we can see this
on brittany's instagram
there are some bizarre behavior and
strange mannerisms that her attorney may
want to
keep from public view the ruling well
the judge sided with jamie for now
refusing to suspend him from his role in
the conservatorship